i want to talk about
nsa surveillance that's been in the news
lately
but most people don't know
how they do it how they actually do it
how can they read our emails how can
they sort of eavesdrop well turns out
it's based on very specific math and
some
super long and super big numbers and i'm
going to show you some of those numbers
that sound good yeah we love numbers
well i have to set it up a little bit i
want to talk a little bit about
something you know which we use it in
our everyday life uh the clock so let's
say you start you start working at nine
in the morning okay and you work for
five hours when do you finish
you finish at two okay but if you
you know if you were to calculate 9 plus
5 you get 14. why do we say 2 pm and not
14
that's because 14
is 12
plus 2. so when we get a result like 14
which is larger than 12 then we sort of
just take the remainder this is called
clock arithmetic and also in mathematics
we call it modular arithmetic because we
say that 9 plus 5 is 2 modulo 12. module
just means that we retain the remainder
so likewise we can imagine a clock which
doesn't have 12 hours but has any other
whole number as the number of hours for
example could be 10 hours could be 5
hours could be you know 5 368
hours but actually in mathematics the
best clocks are the ones in which the
number of hours is a prime number it
turns out that actually there are some
really specific things about this
arithmetic but of course the
sophistication you one can only feel
when that number of hours becomes larger
if it's all modulus 7 or modular 12
there isn't so much room to create
something complicated that we could use
an encryption say but if that number is
zillions of zillions of zillions you
know then that that opens the
opportunity to do something that other
people cannot crack for example when we
send our credit card number online or we
send an email it gets scrambled and then
gets unscrambled at the end point that
is based on this kind of arithmetic
arithmetic with some very large num
prime number of hours and i'll show you
what the actual numbers involved in in a
bit but let me explain a little bit more
about what this algorithms are based on
so first of all they're based on this
clock arithmetic as we already we
already understand that and there is one
more layer which is that we also look at
equations at an equation with two
variables the kind of equations that go
into the algorithms that nsa was able to
crack
have to do with what mathematicians call
elliptic curves so an elliptic curve is
something which is defined by an
equation like this y squared equals x
cubed minus 3x
plus 5. so that's an equation on two
variables x and y to solve this equation
means to find two numbers x and y such
that the left hand side is equal to the
right hand side but there is a crucial
element where exactly do we look for
solutions there are many options of
course the obvious choice would be to
look for solutions say in real numbers
and then this will actually give us a
curve which will look something like
this
you know every point here will have two
coordinates x and y and if you plug them
into this equation left hand side are
equal to the right hand side so that's
the most obvious way to think of
solutions being armed with this new
arithmetic with clock arithmetic we can
also look for solutions module or some
prime number right nothing can stop us
from doing that so for example we can
choose x and y to be
elements of this set of possible hours
on this seven hour clock and we can try
to look for pairs x and y such that the
left hand side is equal to the right
hand side so this way we get something
like think of this as sort of like a
subs some maybe some points on this kind
of curve so there are less solutions
there are fewer solutions for sure
because well to begin with x and y can
only take values from one to seven and
you can sort of think of them as some
special points on this curve and of
course if you take a very large prime
number
then um there will be many more
solutions than if you take a small one
like seven
and there is a whole industry in
mathematics which is called elliptic
curve cryptography
and elliptic curve cryptography has to
do with using this solutions to scramble
and unscramble messages when when they
are under transmitted there are some
standards
in this area which were set by uh by
national institute of standard
technology which is a body in the united
states which
is responsible for this kind of things
he came up with the standards and in
fact you can you can read this is all
public knowledge this was not classified
here is the algorithm just call this
dual dual elliptic curve deterministic
random uh
bits generator
so you see the elliptic curve is
prominently featured here and this is
the equation that's exactly the equation
that i wrote well
it's a very simple equation but you have
to pick a prime number in this document
they actually give you details they
provide you this number p
so see this is the first large number
gives you the largest clock that you've
ever seen look how many digits there are
so that's the that's the clock they're
using in on their curve that's right so
on their curve on the on this on their
equation they're using this many hours
okay so so in in in their day has many
more hours than we're used to
in some sense right and then then there
are some additional some additional data
that have to be used in this algorithm
and so you use those data and as a
result you you create something which
produces numbers that look totally
random those numbers themselves do not
live on the curve but the curve is used
to produce them it's actually very
important problem in mathematics to
produce numbers that that look
completely random so this by itself is
not an encryption algorithm it's not
used to encrypt a specific email or a
specific credit card number but rather
it produces something based on which
other algorithms which would actually be
encrypting your emails or your credit
card numbers be working it'll be based
on that
that's a flowchart which generates
random numbers you start with something
and there's sort of like a loop which
creates more and more and more numbers
and then they get scrambled and then the
output is some number from which you
just extract bits and the way it's set
up it should be so that if they are
completely random that you know if
somebody reads those numbers they cannot
predict what's the next number coming
out so in addition to the to this
equation itself in addition to the prime
number which is given what makes this
work
is a pair of solutions you need this to
kick start things here that's right to
kick start and then to keep going p is
used to run the cycle to produce the
next one and next on the next one and q
is used to kind of scramble the output
of that cycle so that in theory nobody
would be able to predict what's what's
you know the next one think of this
solutions as being some points on a
curve and this by the way is very
difficult to find those solutions
because the numbers involved are huge so
it's not an easy task at all
but this government agency is sort of
simplifying our life and they're saying
look you don't have to look for
solutions yourself we'll give you the
solutions we'll give you these two
points okay so here's p maybe he's here
and q is here
let's just give you this so these are
the numbers actually there you can see
them here oh this is a big money shot
this is our big money shot p x p y q x q
y these are the numbers which the
government says these are the solutions
and actually anybody can this is public
information it's public knowledge
anybody can take these numbers and
substitute in the equation and see that
indeed the equation is satisfied
but they found this for you okay so now
you they suggest to use these two
numbers to run the to run this number
random number generator if all of these
companies
used the same equation
and the same numbers provided by the
government and then started their
flowchart machine
weren't they all generating the exact
same numbers good point there is a seed
also you you have to start with
something and that you can choose
yourself and of course that's what will
distinguish your sequence from other
people's sequence but they give you p
and q which are kind of like
the
the two steps which provide the
information to run the steps of the
procedure right it's a multi it's a
multi-step procedure it's a flowchart
really and to implement those steps you
need those two points and the what is
implicit here is the suggestion that
these two are kind of random p and q are
kind of random that they are not they
don't bear any relation with each other
so it's almost like they give you two
random villages in australia and they
say and you're like you've never been to
australia so you you don't know you know
where they are what the distance between
between them is and you expect that no
one else would know it may not be such a
good analogy because of course in case
of villages in australia you can easily
find out what the distance is but
imagine something where actually it
would be incredibly hard to find the
relation between two numbers
but imagine that somebody actually knows
what the relation is and now we find out
actually nsa apparently did know a
relation
and then the point is that in that case
there is a back door that you can use
that information sort of the distance
between the two villages in australia
you can use it to be able to predict the
outcome of the algorithm once you know
you can observe it for some period of
time and see what numbers are coming out
then you can actually find out what the
next ones are going to be and that sort
of throws a whole sort of a monkey range
in the whole procedure because then it
gives you a way to peek into this other
encryption algorithms which rely on this
random number generator and that's what
happened what has the nsa got or what
did they do that meant they were able to
find the relation but
spies from other countries or
mathematicians like you can't do it or
did they reverse engineer it did they
make the equation they
they reverse engineer it yes that's the
point and uh the the the thing is it's
very hard to find that relation if you
don't already know it and this is
actually the basis of this whole this
whole idea of uh encryption
based on clock arithmetic that there are
certain problems when which you when you
do in clock arithmetic which are
intractable it will take years on even
on a network of super computers to be
able to find a solution
so in the video description there's
going to be a bunch of links you should
have a look at that's going to include
documents that we discussed in this
video they're all public documents
a continuation of the discussion i had
with the professor that didn't make it
into this video and that covers a whole
range of interesting topics like
the people who actually foresaw that
maybe this was a problem
why companies were spoon-fed this
information and also the importance of
mathematics in the world these days it's
worth a look and i'll also include a
link to professor frankel's book
this is it here it's called love and
math it's really good it's worth a look
if you're into mathematics books
and you should be because you're
watching number five and lastly thank
you to everyone for your support through
2013 i'm watching numberphile it's been
great fun making videos like this and
hopefully there's going to be a lot more
in 2014 cheers